Hi.
I'm Dennis Rodman.
I'm the only guy on this stage
has done some really cool shit.
Hey, Ed Norton.
What's up, man?
Edward goes by "Edward" and not
"Ed" because he is a real dick.
[ Laughter ]
Ed Norton was in three
of my favorite things --
"American History X,"
"Fight Club,"
and Salma Hayek.
[ Audience cheers ]
Martha Stewart,
I see you right there, baby.
The next time you go to jail,
please call me.
I will secure your release.
[ Laughter ]
And look at that guy over there,
Lil Rel.
Looking like fuckin'
David Ortiz bobblehead.
[ Laughter ]
Cybill, I see you
over there, baby.
I see you.
Cybill Shepherd --
It sounds like a disease
that you get
when you're fucking a sheep.
[ Laughter ]
Jeff Ross --
Jeff's dick is so small, it
looks like a hat for his nuts.
[ Laughter ]
People have been calling
Joseph a pussy all night.
If one more person calls
Joseph a pussy again,
I'm going to lick him
for 20 minutes.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
Bruce Willis, the last time
I saw you was in the strip club.
-You remember that?
-I do.
Yes, yes, you do.
And, Nikki, you was great
on the stage, baby.
Thank you.
Bruce, you keep making
these fucking bombs.
But guess what.
So does Kim Jong-un.
But at least Kim is smart enough
not to release his.
[ Laughter ]